A kids coding camp is suing critic for speaking out against them.
This is a coding camp named white hat Jr.
They're one of India's big startups and they're in hot water in response.
The mountain criticism they're suing one man named Pradeep ponia I hope I got
that name right for $2.7 million in damages. Okay.
They're accusing of defamation, all sorts of stuff,
which we're going to get into, but they say, look,
it's not because the guy criticized us. It's because he criticized us unfairly.
According to them, legitimate, honest fact-based criticism is truly welcome.
Well, good guy. So they should have no problem with this video right here.
Cause we're going to get to the bottom of this.
We're going to explain what's been going on because I've been looking into this
and what I found is truly astonishing and we're going to take it from the
beginning. Okay, well let's talk code camps real quick. They're giant right now.
It's a gold rush.
Well rather coding is a gold rush and the coding camps or the people selling
shovels, uh, there's a lot of money in selling shovels.
A lot of these coding camps are charging thousands of dollars to teach coding
and they basically hang an Apple or Google job in front of their applicants and
say, well,
isn't it worth it to pay us thousands of dollars to get this education. Now,
one of the things that should be noted is there's a lot of free coding
educations out there, like free code camp.org and many others.
But some people want to go down the paid route because they think they're going
to get a better education.
White hat junior is the latest of many coding camps offering such a thing.
But what makes them different is who their target audience is rather than
targeting people in continuing education or people who are in their twenties.
They're targeting children literally like six years old is where they start up
to age 18 and they make some pretty astounding claims.
Here's one of their ads right here to give you an idea of the type of
advertising they do.
They say space technology is the number one future career for kids.
Your kid can learn to code a spaceship in just 46 minutes,
start free coding and a space tech trial. Uh, okay. First of all, it's not free.
It's about $200 a month.
And obviously it's ridiculous that someone can code a spaceship in 46 minutes,
right?
But they continue with this idea basically telling you that actually the fact
that your kid's so young doesn't mean that they're hindered from learning things
like AI and ML. It actually means they may learn it faster.
And you can see that in their curriculum where they show you how much your kid's
going to be learning. And they tell you things like that,
your kid will get a game developer certificate before they've been through eight
classes of coding. I have your six year old going through seven classes.
And all of a sudden he's coding up candy crush and league of legends.
And this has led many people to criticize their overly simplified and almost
dreamlike promises.
They're making the parents that their kid's going to be the next bill Gates and
ads like this reinforced the point.
They're saying that you can make a $1.2 million salary
at age 13. I mean talk about selling parents, a dream you're saying,
Hey, pay us $200 a month. And your can potentially be working at Google.
It's obviously Google's campus and be making a $1.2 million
salary.
And this is where a lot of the criticism is coming from because not only did
they suggest this as a possibility,
they actually said that one of their students had achieved this meat Wolf.
Guppta an example that white hat Jr was using.
Apparently he learned AI to get a $1.2 million job.
And he's 13 at the time when he did it.
Now here's where the cracks first start to appear because later on in different
ads, their story started to change. Because over here we have Wolf,
Guppta learning computers at age nine. So he,
he actually learned it quicker in the new ad. And he's making 150 crores,
which is actually not just $1.2 million.
It's actually $20 million. So he's younger and making way more money.
And here in another ad, the story changes again.
We're nine-year-old Ryan.
We changed it from Wolf goop D learn computers to earn 150 crores from
Google video while other kids at his age were surfing YouTube videos.
So here they are promoting a story that appears to be false.
And there's no disclaimer about, Hey, this is a fictional story.
It's aspirational, whatever nothing they're saying, this is one of our students.
This really happened. Now, this is where our first critic gets involved.
Prod deep. Poonja started to call them out for this predatory behavior.
And he said, look, you guys are false advertising to parents.
You're not telling the truth about this Wolf, goop to character.
A lot of your stories are fake and he starts publishing a bunch of videos about
it. The problem with that white hat junior doesn't like that.
They don't want negative press.
So what do they do rather than engaging with the criticism and saying, look,
guys, we messed up. We lied.
Instead they start copyright striking the man. Here's a, this guy,
he got five copyright strikes in a row from white hat Jr.
And the company that bought them out. Now they copyright strike this guy.
So many times that he's had to create three different YouTube channels where he
keeps uploading criticisms of white hat Jr. Now, already,
this looks really bad for white hat Jr.
Who claims that they're open to criticism, right?
Remember that at the beginning of the video,
keep giving us feedback to improve legitimate,
honest fact-based criticism is truly welcome. So what's the problem. Well,
they claimed that our critic here is lying and making illegal breaches.
That damage real life. Now, what are they talking about? Well, to find out,
let's go to the lawsuit. First thing to know about this lawsuit.
It's 820 pages long.
The second thing you should know about it is in the lawsuit.
They admit that a lot of the criticism is true. This Wolf goop,
that character doesn't exist. It was a lie. According to white hat Jr.
Themselves, their own lawsuit.
It was an imaginary child who the plaintiffs christened Wolf Gupta.
So it's imaginary. It didn't happen. But nowhere in that thing, did it say it?
They were saying, Hey, we got the student.
He made millions of dollars with our classes. Oh, but actually he doesn't exist.
Didn't you guys know is imaginary. Didn't you didn't you know that? No,
nobody knew it. So they admit in the lawsuit that that is true.
But then call out our guy for saying that plaintiff one had murdered Wolf.
Gooped up when they withdrew their advertisements,
they say the defendant's posts quickly turned sinister subsequent to the
withdrawal of the advertisements to this. I have to say, obviously,
this is a joke when you say, Oh yeah, they murdered Wolf. Gooped up.
That's obviously a joke that the guy's making.
Nobody's going to construe that as literally they killed a kid.
So that's a super bad faith interpretation.
Obviously he's just being tongue and cheek with the fact that suddenly this
mysterious kid, who's your poster child of success, just mysteriously,
vanishes these saying they murdered him. It's a joke.
But then the other giant allegation here is that the defendant hacked into their
Slack communications things. They do,
you see that even hack into plaintiff number two's internal business
communications platform.
And this is actually where things become pretty complicated and things get kind
of muddy because it's true.
That pretty Poonja published to his Twitter and his YouTube channel,
multiple Slack communications from this company.
But what's unclear is how he got them.
Some people have said that they accidentally left their Slack public.
Some people have said that he obtained a CEO password and some people have
said it was a whistleblower that released this to the public.
It's not clear how he got it. In my opinion, obviously hacking, is it okay?
But if it's a whistleblower that came to him and released these images to him,
I think that's a different thing altogether to release those into the public.
If they're a public interest and after reading them,
I definitely think they are.
I'm not saying that any ends justify the means here of how you get them.
But now that they're out in the public,
it's interesting that the fact that they're calling them out for hacking their
platform and releasing them into the public domain,
they're almost confirming that these leaks are indeed real and valid
because obviously if they were fake, they would say, Oh,
he photo-shopped these false things. Instead,
their argument is he took confidential communications and publish them.
Which again, I'm not defending it because we don't know how he got those.
But what the Slack communications reveal now that they're in the public is
pretty damning. I'm going to have to sensor out a lot here, just FYI.
So if you see a blurt, it's because I'm trying to protect, you know,
employee information here.
But basically we see a series of screenshots of employees seeming to be
reporting, uh, criticisms from various Twitter accounts,
from all sorts of things,
contradicting their idea that they're open to criticism. And it's only,
you know,
bad faith criticism that they don't like because they're just reporting
everything.
They even report a depressed employee who says exploitation of teachers and
employees at work and white hat, junior 15 hours working every day,
seven days a week, team leader warranted to terminate.
If raised voice feels frustrated, depressed, the internal Slack says,
can we report the tweet?
Also another one is talking about a negative video and they say, don't reply,
just get the video down. So they don't want to engage with criticism.
They're not interested in that. They just want to censor voices.
But worst of all, I think is this communication,
which came from their C E O okay.
Somebody raised a concern and they posted to a chat where a parent or some kind
of like would be client is asking about an ad that was published where a
13 year old is becoming the CEO of a face detecting app. And they're saying,
one of my students is interested in to see the app made by that student.
Any ideas, how to check that.
So they're saying where's this app that you claim was made by one of your
students and the CEO of white hat Jr. Is saying,
be to create that app now, which is so disgusting,
are you really internalize that they've advertised this thing?
They've created this whole narrative that this was done by a kid.
It can be done by your kid. You should pay us $200 a month because you know,
this is reasonable expectations or at least this is what can be expected.
And this guy is saying that when somebody asks for proof,
he seems to be implying at once that it doesn't exist.
And that if it was to exist, it has to be coded by a professional engineer,
to which one of their employees responds that a person can create and send it as
promised. And they asked, do you want me to another employee response?
I can create the app.
I can not get a 13 year old to create the company around it. At least not now,
which of course not.
And so they're saying internally that they know they can't get a 13 year old to
do this. And this CEO responds that we will,
this is so bad and demonstrates a pattern of behavior.
So Wolf gooped up was not the only one that they did this with it.
Wasn't just one offhand thing, multiple examples they use about,
Oh, these kids are coding these crazy apps and your kids can too,
they are fabricating these narratives, this, this weird thing, right?
Because in the lawsuit, the Slack channel,
like the Slack channel discussion is kind of a poison chalice for white hat, Jr.
Because on the one hand they have a point ponia should not have released private
communications. You know, it depends how he got them.
If he got them through a whistleblower, then he didn't hack them. I mean,
that's just not true. Uh, it just depends.
But the fact that they admit that these Slack communications exist and they seem
to be verifying that they are real is an even worse look for the company
than anything that they've admitted publicly. So that's where the story is now.
Um, it's not believable that white hat Jr is only going after people who are,
you know, being unfair to them.
They are silencing all criticism that comes their way.
It's very clear from the messages that the reporting,
anything and everything that can be construed as criticism at all.
You can be sure that they'll report this video, the report,
any video that talks about them. And frankly,
that's the part that bothers me the most because in order to root out corruption
scams, to tell the frauds from the people who are honest,
you have to that criticism, you have to have the open exchange,
even when it's sort of intense and it can be loaded with some,
a pretty heavy language. You have to have it.
You have to have it for the people who are buying into this stuff.
This is a multi,
multi multi-million dollar company and it needs to be exposed to criticism,
perceive it holds up. And right now they're not doing that.
My hope is as always that the truth comes out. Thanks for watching.
And we may do a follow-up on this. As more information comes out, see you next.
And don't forget to smash like and subscribe. Thank you.
[inaudible].